man needs to send his wife in the
streets let's go style end I'm sleeping
with whomever I want and you're just
gonna sit in the corner and watch
huh it is humiliating I guess in some
aspects it kind of makes me feel like
less of a man sometimes that's not to
say he doesn't do anything special he
just doesn't have intercourse I don't
allow him to do that and no other
females like I'm very possessive he's
mine so he's not allowed to have other
partners not unless I specifically say
so when I'm there but he's made to watch
you have all that kind of parties you
want yes you feel like that's fair
that's not abusive at all
so leave bruv why are you with someone
that makes you feel that less of a man
that doesn't respect you what the [ __ ]
are you doing I don't know there's some
people that like this type of [ __ ] and
have little Arrangements in their
relationship but he obviously does not
like it so why are you still there I
don't get what's going on with some
people's brains bro just leave I've
actually decided that I'm going to stay
single forever I'm here to tell you
right now
I mean the guy I knew what his
intentions were but for me it was never
going past
friendship because I wasn't attracted to
him I thought yeah let me use man for a
free meal because I just want to eat
yeah after work that's deep I never saw
it past anything being a friendship
you're a cool guy but me and you will
never ever did you express that to him
like we are not going anywhere past a
friendship yeah we can go out and eat no
I didn't but so so basically you let him
believe that okay boom There's an
opportunity there's a chance but in your
head you know there is no chance bro
like you're not going anywhere with me
yeah yeah I didn't so basically you use
them yeah I did yeah I did use him and
I'm really proud of it and I'm just
gonna sit here and say it on the podcast
because I'm a [ __ ] donor don't be the
female version
you're [ __ ] donut don't split the
bill and the night and leave
what the [ __ ] is this
somebody's hell told your cat grow your
[ __ ] eyebrows back bro once I'm with
you if I trust any of them what is this
Erica oh I'm in front of this guy on
Instagram you're not so you're not steps
too I'm seven I'm not on my main account
okay he dm'd me I didn't even Rush
my money now until I finish talking
though
so as far as I'm concerned it doesn't
matter because I haven't finished my
friends on Instagram right
Blanca she wasn't prostituting for a
free meal she was leading the guy on he
was courting her taking her out for
meals again and again and again and she
was like no you're never gonna touch
this she wasn't even prostituting
she wasn't even trading she was just
taking and misleading and being a skank
in in the worst possible way just
totally misleading a man who's thinking
he has a chance who's thinking he's
getting somewhere with her it's mean
it's just mean Solace
when they're talking if I don't cut
anybody off when they're talking oh he's
out here teaching basic manners to these
little girls bro one girl that looks
good at 300 pounds I'm not gonna say
anything
I'm not gonna say anything
Tick Tock keeps taking down my videos
now that I really see too many men on
social media going on about body
positivity how they're made to feel bad
about a woman for being overweight for
not having a six-pack for not being over
six foot but I'm always seeing women
going on about it I'm always hearing
them saying let's support each other
let's uplift each other but as soon as
there's that one woman that says [ __ ]
they don't want to hear who they don't
see is being on their side
like a woman's support and like lifting
each other up and girl power so wouldn't
you oh my God wouldn't you suggest that
like you try to actually do that and you
know you don't be like yeah it's okay
that you're [ __ ] you know you wear
the same as a whale like it's no bigger
they just shred shred women that don't
agree with them that have a different
point of view and they and they also
just yes also like I said before they're
jealous there's a lot of jealousy and
they shred women that are doing better
than them can you imagine it's crazy to
say that 500 pound people aren't
attractive what there's somebody's
attracted to a 500 pound person there's
people out there there's something for
everybody but generally to the human and
I there's a there's there's just like a
middle ground that is most the most
considered beautiful that we have almost
no control over what we're attracted to
but don't tell me that I'm an [ __ ] if
I'm not attracted and just take a look
at a woman that's saying this by the way
now take a listen to how [ __ ] her
personality is I have not once in my
life
it's in my life promote positivity well
darling maybe you should [ __ ] try get
a [ __ ] life and cheer up if you put
check your name as indeed I have done
researching this put your name into
Google you get these countless links to
videos the word is that musically
appears immediately that is something
that that you will never ever overcome
however much first of all that's rude
I'm trying to she's a porn star you're
trying to understand that I don't mean
to say you want it to be but it just
it's the way technology the internet
works yeah uh it's I'm not very Google
friendly and we're trying to change that
that's what I said about that too on the
Trump go yesterday like I remember what
did the guy say about her initially he
said if you go you Google her name
you're just going to come up with all
porn references
and um and she's like the face of the
porn industry and she said have you
heard of her no no I don't know she's
and he's she said oh that's rude for
bringing that up and because she's
trying to overcome that and he's like
I'm not trying to be rude I'm just
saying this is what it is what it is and
and I I don't know her at all and I feel
sorry for her if she's you know changed
her life around what what no someone
said is this Mia Khalifa come on bro we
know you know yeah I was asking everyone
knows who she is I was asking like why
is this chick on the news
um so apparently you know she's trying
to she's changed her life and she
doesn't want to be that person anymore
which is great and I applaud her for
that for whatever reason but it is going
to be extreme in today's day and age
impossible to escape from unfortunately
what the [ __ ] these podcast these news
stations to try and clear their name do
they not realize they're making it worse
and just publicizing themselves more and
no matter how many news stations
podcasts you go and it's never going to
be forgotten kids are going to see it
their kids are going to see it their
kids are going to see it because it's
not called the internet you don't know
um I honestly didn't want to have kids
or get married or any of that and so I'm
very like pleased and happy that this
ended up happening now even if she
manages to get married one day and find
a man who wants to settle down with her
there's still going to be loads of
problems coming out from her past
there's still going to be times where he
thinks about that no he gets upset about
that it's going to be really hard more
or less impossible for you to have a
normal relationship what's the most
amount of guys you've spoken to at the
same time
four four [ __ ] damn so what about you
I'm sorry just one at a time I'm
respectful like that I'm sorry I'm gonna
play off so that's it though I'm sorry
excuse me most girls these days have got
more than one guy to be consumed at the
same time you don't have to be the best
looking girl in the world to have more
than four guys speaking to you the thing
is it's like what's your plan is that
your day job like just scamming all four
of them or what
say your day jobs
[Music]
it's the evil world we live in hey man
joke or not if she let it happen and she
kept walking he can have her I saw the
cutest voice so I tried to take him with
me but
absolutely no game and if you swap the
rolls we know they'll be up rule would
there be yeah totally the fact that she
called him daddy in the video it makes
me just like that's just yeah she was
just being married
oh yeah but you're way too pretty and
I'm way too pretty and she is way too
pretty that's the problem
yeah
no yeah all right that's what happens I
know yes if I have any advice about men
and guys always take care of you yes but
guys and you he'll catch you if not go
[ __ ] them yeah you're like an old soul I
can tell but like yes don't take any
[ __ ] yeah where we deserve you're gonna
be a [ __ ] and exactly what goes out
what goes around and comes around you
this website yesterday about never
settled like what the [ __ ] does that
mean yeah what I was just gonna say the
same thing what do you mean never settle
what what literally what does she mean
by that it means if somebody's not
treating you well don't you know don't
take it like is that right yeah I mean
don't settle for less than you deserve
that's a fair thing to say though yeah
of course it is no man's good enough
comes along you can keep lying to
yourself and stay single to your 40 50
years old but at the end of the day
you're just gonna be stuck with a bunch
of cats
rappers you guys tend to fool around a
little which I I am I've cheated plenty
of times in my life by the way but I'm a
reformed cheater I've never I would
never do it again stop the cap okay
so never again who is this guy ever
again I mean I don't know if I believe
you but I mean no I won't I won't do it
I won't do it would you just break up
with them
that's the thing yeah that's what I've
learned well done break up like break up
be done it's it's [ __ ] stupid
sometimes if it's going to be a one-off
thing and you sleep with someone one
time and then you'll never cheat again
and like you don't ever talk to that
person again it says the reform theater
it's not it
oh my God
FBI open up acceptable it's not
acceptable but like it's more
understandable oh really I think okay
everyone deserves a one-time don't
expect loyalty from her everyone
deserves a one-time cheat no no either
you're why do you do why do you deserve
a one either you keep your word or you
don't what do you provided to the
relationship on what what why do you
deserve a one-time cheat explain to me
because she's a bad [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here in their relationship
because YOLO she's a one-time I disagree
you do yes if you're dating sure but
once you're married once you're married
so the reform cheat and it's cheated
plenty of times but still cheat she was
able to get away with it and Norm would
find out whether you're dating or
married if you cheat she belongs to the
streets it belongs to the streets
gone
[Music]